voy a hacer varios ejemplos usando la
regla de la cadena en este vídeo así que
empecemos una vez voy a tomar
fd x igual a esta herramienta no me
gusta no no esto está quedando muy
cortado mejor voy a poner una
herramienta de brasil
fx igual ahí voy a pensar en una función
me gusta la función x ubican más 2 x
cuadrada y esto le voy a quitar x y voy
a tomar ahora exponentes negativos para
cambiarle un poco van a ver que al final
funciona igual entonces voy a tomar x a
la menos dos y todo esto lo voy a elevar
a la menos 7 muy bien estamos usando la
regla de la cadena así que si de repente
ustedes me dicen oye sal es si yo
multiplico todo más bien hago esta
operación a la menos 7
podría resolverlo pues tal vez sí pero
se van a tardar una eternidad es mucho
mejor utilizar la regla de la cadena así
que vamos a utilizar la que me decía la
regla de la cadena agarra el polinomio o
la función que tienes adentro de este
caso es un polinomio de x entonces
agarra el polinomio que tenemos adentro
y deriva lo entonces primero hay que
derivar lo que está adentro y cuál es la
derivada de x cúbica pues es 3 veces x
cuadrado y cuál es la derivada de 2x
cuadrada pues es 4x bajamos el exponente
2 x 2 4x muy bien y ahora cuál va a ser
la derivada de menos x a la menos 2 pues
menos x menos me va a dar más y 2 x 1 me
va a dar 2 entonces me va a quedar más 2
x a la que potencia pues es menos 2 ya
esto le restamos 1 o sea menos 2 - 1 - 3
hasta aquí todo en orden ya con esto
acabamos la primera parte de mi derivada
que era la derivada de lo que estaba
dentro del paréntesis y bueno a esto hay
que multiplicarlo a como si tuviéramos x
al menos 7 construyamos una función
elevada a la menos 7 por las reglas del
exponente lo que tenemos que hacer es
bajar el exponente y poner la función
del cual y después bajarle 1 exponente
entonces vamos a hacerlo menos 7 bajo el
exponente pongo mi paréntesis ya dentro
de paréntesis voy a poner la función tal
cual igualita a cómo está escrita arriba
x cúbica más 2 x cuadrada menos x a la
menos 2
y todo esto elevado a la menos siete
menos uno o sea menos ocho bien me quedo
un poco amontonado entonces voy a tratar
de repetirlo aquí para que quede mucho
más claro entonces efe prima de x es
igual a quien a pues le voy a escribir
otra vez todo tal cual y ahorita vamos a
simplificar 3x cuadrada más 4 x más 2 x
a la menos 3
ya está aquí cierro el paréntesis lo voy
a multiplicar esto es un menos 3 está un
poco feo pero bueno lo voy a multiplicar
por menos 7 x al cubo más 2 x al
cuadrado menos x a la menos 2
y todo esto elevado al menos 8 bien creo
que aquí está más entendible y ahora lo
que voy a hacer es multiplicar este
menos 7 por cada uno de mis sumando sea
dentro del paréntesis darse cuenta que
solamente lo puede multiplicar por el
primer paréntesis porque por el segundo
paréntesis de una potencia la menos 8
entonces menos 7 por 3 es menos 21 x
cuadrada menos 7 por 4 es menos 28 x y
menos 7 por 2 es menos 14 x a la menos 3
y todo esto que multiplica a x al cubo
más 2 x cuadrada
- a x a la menos 2 y todo esto elevado
al menos 8 ya no pongo el 7 porque el 7
lo ya lo acabo de multiplicar este menos
7 muy bien y pues aquí ya tengo la
derivada utilice la regla de la cadena y
ya con esto tengo la derivada de mi
función que yo quería derivar en un
principio bien se cuenta que esta
derivada es tiene una trampita tiene
como una regleta más bien la regla es
derivar primero lo que está dentro bajas
el exponente pues es la función del cual
y después le restas 1 el exponente muy
bien ahora voy a intentar ver un caso un
poco más difícil y más interesante si
hacemos este caso nuevo seguramente ya
van a entender todo lo de la regla de la
cadena en este caso es un poco más
difícil pero vale la pena verla entonces
vamos a tomarlo y espero también que se
hayan dado cuenta de que volver bien
rápido el pizarrón pero
ahora sí voy a decir que estos fx un
poco más oscuro porque muy claro ni lo
van a ver
fx es igual a me voy a tomar 3 veces x
elevado a la menos 2 ya esto lo voy a
sumar a 5x elevado al cubo menos menos 7
x esto elevado a la 5 y toda la
expresión elevada al cubo y seguramente
te va a decir hijo de sal hacer esto nos
va a llevar una eternidad mejor hacemos
algo más fácil pero usando la regla de
la cadena van a ver que es muy fácil
quien va a ser mi primera derivada de
esto mi derivada con respecto a x bueno
primero voy a usar muchos colores para
que ustedes vayan dando cuenta de dónde
sale cada cosa voy a tomar lo que está
más adentro de todos los paréntesis de
expresión que tienen muchos paréntesis
es lo que me voy a tomar y bueno vamos a
ver el panorama general voy a derivar la
expresión que está dentro de todos los
paréntesis y después la expresión más
grande después la más grande y después
y aunque esto no es un término
matemático y así les va a quedar un poco
más claro entonces primero vamos a
derivar lo que está más adentro de mi
expresión lo que está adentro de muchos
paréntesis y por su derivada es de 5 x
cúbica es 15 x cuadrada y de ides menos
7 x es menos 7 bien y ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo voy a tomar otro color
recuerden que este va a ser el ejercicio
de los colores muy bien después hay que
multiplicarlo por la derivada de lo que
sigue de algo un poco más grande la
derivada de lo que está de verde pero
eso utilizando la regla de la cadena es
como si tuviéramos x a las 5 o sea es 5
abrimos paréntesis ponemos la función
tal cual recuerda que la derivada de x a
las 5 y 5 x 4 pero que como es una
función es cinco veces la función tal
cual 5x cúbica menos 7 x y le bajamos 1
el exponente elevado en la cuarta 5
veces 5 x cúbica menos 7 x elevado a la
cuarta muy bien
hasta aquí vamos la derivada de del
color verde
ahora vamos a tomar la siguiente
derivada voy a cambiar de color otra vez
para tomar la derivada de lo que sigue
entonces la derivada de lo que sigue va
a ser la derivada de 3x a la menos 2
esto lo voy a hacer con color rosa
entonces la derivada de 3x al menos 2
pues es menos 6 x a la menos 3 bajo el
menos 2 y menos 2 por 3 es menos 6 x a
la menos 2 menos uno que es menos 3 bien
hasta aquí tenemos la derivada de todo
esto que está de color morado todo esto
es lo que derivado hasta ahorita
muy bien ahora lo que quiero hacer es la
derivada de toda la expresión completa
como si tuviera una función elevada a
una potencia entonces voy a agarrar un
nuevo color pero si quiero que se den
cuenta que hasta ahorita tengo toda la
derivada de lo que está dentro ahora
solamente me falta derivar lo que está
afuera lo que está hasta el último que
es la derivada de una función elevada
una potencia entonces bajo la potencia
pongo toda la función igualita como
estaba 3x a la menos dos más abro
paréntesis y tengo que poner 5x cúbica
menos 7x y todo esto elevado a las 5 y
después toda esta expresión elevada a la
tres menos uno o sea elevado a la 2 y
aquí lo tienen ya por fin tenemos la
derivada gracias a la regla de la cadena
y tal vez sea un ejemplo un poco confuso
pero es de los ejemplos más difíciles
que les pueden poner en un examen
utilizando la regla de la cadena aunque
si se dan cuenta realmente no era tan
difícil fíjense primero tomé la derivada
de lo que estaba hasta adentro 5 x
cómicas
es 15 x cuadrada y la derivada de menos
7 x era menos 7 y después tomé la
derivada de lo que estaba de verde que
era un paso arriba era un poquito más
grande y su derivada era bajamos el 5 lo
ponemos la función tal cual 5x cúbica
menos 7x y todo esto lo elevamos a la
potencia 4 y después de vive este
sumando que quedaba aquí solito que era
menos 6x cúbica y eso fue la derivada de
todo lo que estaba dentro y ya para
finalizar lo que hizo fue derivar toda
la función elevado a la potencia 3
espero realmente lo haberlos confundido
mucho y si lo hice les pido una disculpa
sin embargo en el siguiente vídeo vamos
a seguir viendo más ejemplos y más
problemas de regla de la cadena en algún
punto de estos vídeos va a tener sentido
lo que estamos haciendo y viendo más y
más ejemplos va a ser mucho más fácil
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo